set your goal and never fear from it
cool i got a better idea how about the
end must be adjusted to the means
right it's that's not very interesting i
want that lambo
i want a dream board i got a lambo and i
got an infinity pool
cool how's that wendy's
salary kicking in right
adjust your means a little bit man
adjust the end to fit the means
you know sure oh this is this is again
no one's there's no there's no there's
not one single
inspirational meme on the gram that says
that says the end must be adjusted to
the means no one says that actually it's
the opposite
as far as in the inspirational uh quotes
industry well for lack of a better term
it's the exact opposite actually oh yeah
yeah
it's like hey basically it's like okay
adjust the men's to the means right or
the into the means right so it's kind of
like hey don't
freaking have this goal that's like
unrealistic essentially essentially yeah
fact like it's unrealistic
right like it's irresponsible it's your
response you have an irresponsible goal
right there
you can like whatever kill yourself
doing it right you should go and the
comment should be like
you're dumb it shouldn't be right given
that
right but if you say it but they'll talk
about there's someone right now that's
going to hear this music
that's kind of [ __ ]
oh yeah if you're down for the thing and
i get it because double tap
uh heart like if you want to be a
you know for your first hundred million
oh yeah full yeah
oh there's people that tap that twice oh
yeah right 100
yes sir and and like for a moment
they're kind of like pumped
yeah i'm sure they're pumped the whole
time
until the ends really but no well if
you're the guy if you're the guy who
says this
what this book is saying hey like the
end must be adjusted to the means that's
a good goal
like that's a lofty goal which you know
obviously
you can't hate on lofty goals wait
that's not even really a lofty goal
that's just a realistic thing to do as a
human but the realizations are making
realistic human memes
yeah well in a way you know because the
first one would be the end must be
adjusted to them
it's very not inspirational they would
get down voted
yeah you'll you'll be branded as the
hater really oh like that's what that's
the point where they
they'll brand you as a hater it's like
everyone's always hating and
this goes into uh the whole idea dave
that you were talking about of like
about hey this isn't really sexy this is
the absolute like
non this is getting down voted this is
getting haters
and and what's interesting is who you
gonna who's gonna get the
up vote right yeah this person is
getting
you're getting hated oh yeah because
you're like actually it's an unrealistic
goal you should check yourself
right oh the downer the doubter right oh
yeah
yeah and the thing is i get it because
every once in a great while you'll get
someone who
achieved this super lofty goal not to
say that they didn't adjust the ends to
the means because they had the means
apparently at the end of the day the
means were there because the end is
there too right
but here's the thing they had that uh uh
uninspirational memes we'll just say
realistic realistic memes
yeah yeah but unless they they
achieved that goal that was kind of
untip not typically
realistic it was unrealistic right
comparatively speaking of whatever
and they achieved it i mean we could
easily argue that like oh
this person did this because they had
the meme the means
right well that horsepower they had the
educational thing they had they had all
these things set up so it's actually a
realistic goal i know that that's what
i'm saying where
but they'll take the the the crazy quote
unquote unrealistic
uh ends right the goal we'll say
president but that's the one right the
classic
president of the united states you can
do anything you want well i'm going to
set my goal the highest i possibly can
in life president united states
right so they'll be like all right cool
therefore we should all essentially set
goals as high as president united states
right okay that's kind of the
inspirational message
right okay meanwhile the very few
individuals that became president united
states had the means
so their ends technically by definition
were adjusted their ends were adjusted
to the means
because they had the means you see what
i'm saying not everyone has the money
yes
so you gotta adjust those yeah meanwhile
everyone's saying no no no no no
don't if he can do it i can do it too
right
which hey i'm not saying they can't i'm
not even saying that
but i'm saying hey man you gotta be
really realistic on that kind of stuff
yeah
see i'm saying but then if you say that
you just can't say that you know what's
really crazy is like i just got
slapped in my own face thinking about
this because we're kind of
joking about this but what he's saying
and what he
saw was
hundreds and hundreds of thousands of
soldiers
that were killed because the leadership
didn't adjust the ends to the means
totally
which is crazy to think about and as you
guys were talking i was thinking in my
mind like
people have figured this out there there
are even phrases out there the one i
kept thinking of as you're talking about
this is
i remember the phrase live within your
means
like i've heard that's a phrase what
it's not is
it's not hanging on a poster in any
kid's bedroom anywhere
yeah like i don't go to bed at night
like it's a nine-year-old going
i'm gonna live within my means the irony
inside that is the best way to
actually ultimately expand your means
over time so your means get greater and
greater is to do exactly that
like that's that's the trick to it is is
the
the dissatisfaction of the reality is
something people
overlook and the the the unfunny part of
that
which is the sobering piece that you
just mentioned is that it can actually
lead people down a path to do exactly
what you
just said which which almost seems
not possible except for the fact that
these that he specifically
lived that in a way that goes what are
we doing
here what are we doing what are we
expending
to a con and what are we accomplishing
by doing that so it wasn't just the
national exhaustion
it was the national exhaustion with
nothing to show for it
and then the scale of that which is
which is impossible
as opposed to hey why don't we operate
within our means here
why don't we do that yeah and if you
fast forward the kid
if there was a kid that had a poster on
their wall that said live within your
means
and therefore they're saving and they're
putting together and you look at them in
20 years
and they're in a way better position
than someone that was like
you know you need the lambo or whatever
right because they're going to end up in
debt and they can't invest properly
and the they have to work a job that
they don't really like and it's a job
that's a dead end
like all these things add up you said
something about
you being a nba basketball player right
i would say
on record on a inspirational or
demotivational post saying hey bro
that's
unrealistic i would tell you that yeah
yeah and i think
factually it is un well as far as
factually goes
it is unrealistic i don't know that i
would tell a high school kid that
when he's really into basketball i don't
know if i would i would
say that like it'd be unrealistic in
certain ways like if under certain
circumstance or whatever but
given like how you consider it most
people how they get into like
professional
sports whatever they work hard they
really love the sport you know
they go through trials and tribulations
or whatever and they end up making it
kind of a thing
so if you get someone that that's kind
of in the beginning of that
type of path right where that path is
not straight up blocked off for whatever
reason like it would be in your case
i wouldn't really say that's unrealistic
the point is there are really cases
where it's
unrealistic so if you tried to
be an nba player hired the best coach in
the world
i i get it you would wind up
exhausting all your resources i should
adjust my my end times
yes sir you might want to make sure that
your kid who you don't want to stifle
that dream you might want to make sure
that they're not putting
all their eggs in that one basket and
two like hey listen
go for it but you're not going to drop
out of school
you're not going to stop doing this and
this
with the the ultimate meme of
focus on your goals and block out every
distraction so i
i'm done with school because school
stupid school ain't going to help me be
an nba player meanwhile
you're five six you're done growing
you're not that good of a shot but
you've got this
this passion you might want to keep that
kid on the track of
hey cool i'm not here to crush your
dreams however comma let's consider some
other things as you're doing